you're going to be hearing more about
Qatar than ever before but just how
familiar are you with the country
hosting the World Cup let's see how many
facts we can get through in under one
minute this is what Qatar looked like 40
years ago and this is what it looks like
today it's gone through a major
transformation it's a peninsula on the
Arabian Gulf 160 kilometers long 80
kilometers wide and Doha is the capital
almost 3 million people live here 87
percent of the residents are from other
countries the state religion is Islam
and it's a constitutional monarchy led
by an emir bin Hamad al-sani it's from
this fort that the emir's great great
grandfather fought off the Ottomans the
family went on to reach a deal with the
British for military protection for much
of the 20th century until Qatar declared
independence in 1971. before oil and gas
were discovered Qatar had a small
population that focused on pearling and
fishing since then it's become one of
the richest Nations per capita the
climate is pretty standard for a desert
it's super hot with summer temperatures
reaching around 50 degrees Celsius but
now in November and December it's much
cooler you won't see any mountains here
that's because its highest point is just
103 meters making Qatar the second
flattest country in the world great for
a football pitch or eight
[Applause]